[Music]
this is the town of Chippewa Falls
nestled along the Chippewa River in the
beautiful North Woods of Wisconsin
it's home to the lining Coogler family
and the jacob lining kugel Brewing
Company Brewer of Leinenkugel's summer
Shandy and one of the oldest breweries
in America so what's it take for one
family to keep the beer flowing for over
a hundred 50 years it's harder than
you'd think
our story begins in 1867 with a young
German immigrant a brewer named Jacob
line in Kouvola
I like to refer to my great-great
grandfather is no-neck lining for
centuries his family had been brewing
beer in Germany now he was looking to
make his mark in America in Chippewa
Falls Jacob discovered a source of pure
spring water which makes for a great
lager style beer he also discovered
2,500 thirsty Lumberjacks so he built a
brewery but brewing was hard work to
make ends meet he enlisted his family I
think the hardest worker out of that
family probably his wife Josephine
my great-great-great grandmother every
day she woke up at 3 a.m. to cook four
meals for the 20 brewery workers all
while raising four children a lot of
credit goes to Josephine the little
brewery prospered but then Jacob's
partner quit and Josephine died of
pneumonia aged 44 with a family to
support
Jacob had no choice but to keep ruing
and the people of Chippewa Falls loved
the beer so much they elected Jacob
mayor twice they continued to brew great
beer all the way up until the federal
government put us out of business in
1920 the United States bans the
manufacture and sale of alcohol
the dark days of prohibition descended
upon America and hundreds of breweries
vanished we had to stay in business and
had to stay together as a family to
survive prohibition they turned to
Jacobs daughter Susan electing her
president just six years after women won
the right to vote third cousin twice
removed you have to go back through a
family of lineage to find that she saved
Leinenkugel's by brewing soda pop and
mixers I got to believe that the mixers
were being mixed with something else
when Prohibition came to a close to
other line and kugel women Catherine
laning kugel and Rose Caspar came to the
rescue
they actually mortgage their homes to
get the brewing equipment back up and
operating not a lot of breweries came
out of prohibition mining kugels was
fortunate the reinvigorated brewery was
soon joined by Bill line and kugel a
marine returned from war bill my dad was
really the guy that expanded the paris'
footprint and into the North Woods of
Wisconsin bill had five children and
they helped out around the brewery as
bill hit the road spreading the gospel
of Leinenkugel's across the North Woods
he just went out and met the people put
a nice cold linings in her hands and
they loved the guy and that's what they
stuck with soon he had transformed
Leinenkugel's into a major Midwest
brewery but it wasn't enough small
Brewers were being priced out of
business by big Brewers who had invaded
their turf economics 101 folks back when
Leinenkugel's got started there were
nearly 4,000 breweries spread across
America by the late 70s only 89 remained
as Leinenkugel's became engulfed and the
price wars ash for Leinenkugel's it
received help from a fellow Wisconsin
brewery the 1987 that my dad received a
letter from Miller Brewing Company my
dad says I think they want us to buy
them
well it was obviously the other way
around Leinenkugel's kept its family
roots and bills three sons built upon
their father's legacy after partnering
with Miller Brewing Company we began to
develop different styles of beers that
we probably wouldn't have been able to
do on our own
[Music]
there's quite a feel so you'll have to
have some more film line and kugel
original honey vice berry vice canoe
paddler sunset wheat creamy dark big but
doppelbock what else lining Google's
summer Shandy
it wasn't until the development of
lighting Google's summer Shandy that we
decided to take lining Google's to the
rest of the country whether it's the
island of Manhattan New York or all the
way up to the great frontier of Alaska
that's pretty cool
[Music]
in 2017 Leinenkugel's celebrated 150
years as the pride of the Northwoods and
with time comes tradition line of kugels
and Chippewa Falls are synonymous when
you say Leinenkugel's you think chip
will fall Wisconsin when you say chip
will Falls Wisconsin you think line of
kugel beer
there's generations of Leinenkugel's
that have worked here at the brewery but
there's also been generations of other
families that have worked here and
continue to work here to this day our
hats off go to them as well it's a
legacy that was started in 1867 and
we're going to work really hard to
ensure that that legacy continues
[Music]
you
[Music]